[Music]
so in against the grain mm-hmm
submitted by hello Barton hello
a very politically incorrect TV show is
breaking audience records this TV show
is called taboo and it's in Belgium they
have great waffles it has broken TV
records what their whole thing here is
they make fun of things you shouldn't be
making fun of that's tight that is is
it's like worldwide or is in Belgium in
Belgium so it's like a hundred thousand
people yeah I'm just kidding that's
dough that's my whole existence as a
person dude they tell jokes about
paraplegics amputees and minorities ty
has dubbed welcome to just kiddin news
Maui we were pretty censored the stuff
that I really want to say I kind of it
and more and more over the years I think
that's all comic so like you've gotta
you can't say you can't do that you
can't do the writers room [ __ ] yeah even
the stuff that I really want to say I'll
get mad at myself later I literally
after I say like why did you say that
because there's there's writers room
talk and then there's like yeah you know
writers rooms aren't that safe anymore
though yeah yes but it's [ __ ]
ridiculous dude comedy clubs aren't safe
writers rooms aren't safe it's like it's
so [ __ ] dumb dude yeah I need a safe
space for comics where we can say
whatever the [ __ ] we want
no the lineup of the first victim slash
guests included obese and poor people
drawer terminal mental illness gays
blind people and people of color so they
bring people on they just start roasting
the [ __ ] oh my god that would be a dull
concept it's done respectfully so what
they do is they did you respectfully do
that so we get the lineup of people and
then they spend a few days with them
getting to know them yeah
pretty much are they're building
ammunition with the people involved in
this like they're in the know to like
it's not like done behind their back and
then a few months later the comedian
then invites them to a packed theater
filled with people that are like them is
loves going on it's already like the
best show on earth
and then they they just want to do like
a politically incorrect comedy routine
based on them so for example one of the
jokes was quote there are a lot of
advantages of having a child without
arms and then everyone be like it won't
it won't pick its nose or put its elbow
on the table that's funny yeah oh let's
see you know why this works you get to
know their world yeah mm-hmm so there's
a difference between like like a ching
chong joke yeah and then understanding
asian culture making fun of certain
things yes exactly yes Russell Peters he
does the accent he understands a lot of
[ __ ] is not Chinese but he understands
that that's why it's [ __ ] hilarious
yeah it's awesome cuz it's not like look
at the guy the [ __ ] wheelchair he
can't use his legs
haha it's not like one of those you know
it's it's something else I [ __ ] love
this [ __ ] this is great guys no I would
like that show - actually just just
because yeah I like both show somebody
just walks in and then you just start
roasting yep that's what I like - and
the person doesn't know what they're
walking into either yeah because they're
in a tube right now in a cage and it's
just just comics sitting around them and
they just get roasted in front of a
whole on I have an idea they should make
a show that's like American Idol except
that's gonna be called roaster okie and
so what happens is you have three
commits so it's like karaoke but it's
roasting so you have three comedians
right they're standing right there you
don't know who the guest is the minute
the guest turns around you see their
face they just kind of start going off
and roasting the [ __ ] reowww key part if
you know wonderkid you're singing a song
like you don't really know or maybe you
do but you see like the words and like
the blues yeah looks like that so the
person is the words rose Brouillette
rose turn around
start rose enough oh let's make that
show that sounds [ __ ] funny dude and
that'd be cool too they can know they'll
give like the comic you know let's not
even do that it's not even that they'll
know the person either give him a few
things about their personal life and
they could bring it up that should it be
[ __ ] no way and it's gotta be
something sad like some heartstring [ __ ]
like this guy he's always wanted to be a
school teacher but he's always been in
like the special ed class he couldn't be
a one but now this is his chance to
shine so you turned that guy around and
now you have three comedians oh love it
look delete that [ __ ] out of this video
right now something to take a [ __ ] yeah
so this show is just gained so much
popularity and they've even been
approached to create this show and us
like adapt it to US Britain France
Netherlands please Finland Denmark you
know what's so interesting like I would
realize about myself like because like
as you get older usually what happens
you tend to mellow out
you don't give too many [ __ ] about
things right I can't really like roast
people as well as I used to cuz I just
don't care enough to don't have enough
anger yeah cuz you know like back in the
day it was like you and your homies you
guys roasting the [ __ ] out of each other
that skill has died for me I can't
really do with that because you gotta be
petty to roast yeah you have to be petty
you have to admit pick on this and you
if they're not worried about their
feelings at all whatsoever because now
when I state things I'm like oh you
worry about their feelings any things
don't bother you as much so you can't
roast yeah so you're so accepting David
yeah like it's kind of sucks cuz like my
whole career was pissed I'll be roasting
the [ __ ] out of people and now like I'll
write some stuff and I'm like yeah
that's a little out of pocket that was
kind of mean yeah what happened well if
you got let's say they invite like guest
comedians and you guys can invite
anything you go in well I would have to
warm myself up because when Tim was
doing his roast I got really happy so
that was exciting and he actually gave
me like a couple weeks to think of [ __ ]
to write about so like really good month
like a couple months oh that's why I
mean you hang out like a warm-up what a
bunch people that hate me and I think
just go back and forth then it'll be
good but even even with that I was
do ya I love a lot of things you know
especially a specialist you know him
know him but also like I don't know you
guys know the channel all deaf digital
yes yes today they do a lot of roasts
things they had a show called roast me
which was kind of that somebody stands
on a rotating thing but there was no
like backstory yeah but they know the
person so they know but it was mostly
just on appearance and [ __ ] like that
yeah yeah it's gotta get personal but
yeah but talk about a traumatic
childhood or something like hashtag
roast me like hold a photo yeah yeah
that's big no that's not enough see like
if he's just appearance alone yeah it's
gotta you know when like when you in
American Idol when they show the guy
like the the town that he grew up in and
it looks like the brothers [ __ ] the
sisters and it looks like they never
wanted her lon like if you got to see
that whole image and you just give them
like 30 seconds of material then the
comedian go in on them like a
[ __ ] yeah see they had no
backstory but it was like I'm gonna look
at you and create a backstory yeah sir
like that and then they have this other
thing oh it's the same title but they
revamped it so now they're all in the
classroom and then one gets up to the
board
you know they because we need these type
of shows who we do even when I was like
doing these videos towards the ladder
and right because I basically just roast
the [ __ ] out of somebody but then it was
like my level of roasting was
insensitive to people they're like whoa
you're going to fart and I was like wait
what's roasting to you guys then it's
all I looked at of some new like younger
popular channels they're not really
saying anything yeah they're just like
look at where they are you still look so
stupid but they'll say like some
personal [ __ ] and then I'm going too far
I'm like but that's what it was though
you had roast means that somebody's lit
on fire you don't want some Jeffrey Ross
type yeah he goes in on is crazy and the
people are like that's too far too far
what the [ __ ] what's going on with this
what's the point of roasting though is
to go too far the point of it is to like
hurt their feelings
because now like they're like you're not
flirting like some of the younger
youtubers like their term of roasting is
like you're irrelevant okay oh I know
these kids it like oh my god he roasted
him so bad
I'm like how the [ __ ] is that roasting
dude yeah I literally said that your
cousin's [ __ ] each other that's why
you're so [ __ ] ugly you [ __ ] oh oh
and that's the start that's the opening
the opening one then that's an appetizer
it's a drop in the bucket yeah that's
not even that personal blame MTV
what happened that show yo mama oh yeah
it started all the we gross funny on
that 70 show though he's so hilarious
they had it like a dance-off to where
they had a crowd and then they would
have a one-on-one dude they had this is
one joke I was dying though there was
like this big ass kid right and he was
like a black kid but he was like super
into goth and there's other killings
roasting the [ __ ] at him there's like
those don't even [ __ ] like spiked
bracelet doesn't meat tenderizers you
fat [ __ ] called meat tenderizers but
roasting isn't also just saying [ __ ] you
no no [ __ ] you have to be creative and
clever be creative it's like a battle
rap yeah yeah battle rappers are still
like the og Roasters yeah they're
[ __ ] good man yeah they just do it to
a rhythm and a beak they just do it to a
rhythm and a beep you [ __ ] but this
show is fun yeah there is their footage
no oh I want to see you like some I
think I'm gonna watch it I don't know if
their humour is the same as ours might
be lost in translation to well you said
they'd fill the theatres with people
that are that are like so when they make
fun of the blind guy you have a
beautiful of mine people that's exactly
what I imagined cuz when I imagine like
the [ __ ] like a wheelchair guy I saw
the whole crowd we make fun of the deaf
people you know whatever reminds me have
you seen that key and peele sketch where
there's a guy does a burn victim he was
doing stand-up dude that [ __ ] was so
[ __ ]
so so keegan-michael Keys doing stand-up
right and he's like roasting people in
the crowd and also the spotlight goes on
this verdict of right I think any
passive over and the guy feels like the
electronic boy he goes what about heels
what about me
me anybody anybody make fun of the birds
I just did want to make a joke about
this guy cuz I thought he wasn't come at
me in my nightmares like no he told me -
you told me genius
I can't tell that's [ __ ] genius yeah
what having tears laughing dudes that's
a genius you know it's funny about like
this whole show so they're like people
with disabilities obesity all that and
then people of color like minorities
like like like damn we're all the same
level of like but we're not so we're
just not regular human you know we're as
good as a deaf person blind person yeah
we're a deformity right like what we're
dissing [ __ ] I mean do you think it
would be as funny if they just had
normal white people er [ __ ] you
this is a no-holds-barred if you're deaf
blind or asian everybody like minorities
are really like minorities yeah like who
goes to Belgium that's true no one I
don't know anyone not even [ __ ] yeah
I don't know anything but waffles about
Belgium news yeah I can't wait til they
adapted those to you guys I really want
to watch it I bet you that US is gonna
make it weak no we're not getting it you
the TV here is so [ __ ] weak man
there's no way we're getting it yeah
[Music]